foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
metagirl fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
came back a totaled dick oh please he
left out some important information but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
all in the ground
my sacred mission
is to create a perfect Society
didn't want to make things perfect
you just hated things the way they are
[Music]
I want you all to know that I am
grateful to fight beside my friends
incinerate that
foreign
[Applause]
until we found each other
are you ready for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
[Music]
a beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what I've never noticed how
black your eyes were they were replaced
by my father as a method of torture he
he picked a pretty set
[Music]
thank you